[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt wieder ein leckeres
türkisches rezept ich mache ja und zwar
ist es auch bekannt als türkische pizza
gibt es zum beispiel in imbissläden also
in dünner leben und es wird immer so
schön zusammengerollt kann man bisschen
salat ein wollen viele machen es auch
mit döner fleisch wobei ich finde
fleisch im fleisch geht absolut nicht
aber auf jeden fall ist es eine sehr
leckere pizza und ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach kurz die zutaten und dann legen
wir auch direkt los also für den
hefeteig brauche ich ein kilo mehl und
das ist übrigens auch das mehl wonach
ihr mich fragt dass sich dieses feine
aber das ist ein ganz normales 405
weizenmehl ist einfach von der marke
globus ich habe ich zwei teelöffel
zucker
ich brauche zwei teelöffel salz einen
würfel frischhefe sind 42 gramm 500
milliliter warmes wasser und etwas
olivenöl so etwa sechs es läuft und ich
mache jetzt zuerst das wasser in die
schüssel dann gebe ich da nicht hilfe
mit rein damit die sich schön auf helfen
kann ihr könnt auch mit trockenhefe
arbeiten da braucht er dann einfach zwei
päckchen dann löse ich das hier mit so
einem schneebesen auf es gibt auch
direkt das restliche wasser mit dazu da
ist mir übrigens gerade hereingefallen
also deswegen ist es aus beton und hier
kommt auch der zucker mit rein
der darf sich auch trotz auflösen
dann setzt sich jetzt schon mal den
knethaken 1
ihr könnt aber den teig natürlich auch
mit den händen verkneten als ihr braucht
keine küchenmaschine und jetzt kommt
schon mal etwa die hälfte des mails mit
dazu dann darf das schon mal durchkneten
und dann gebe ich nach und nach den rest
und noch zwei teelöffel salz und rein
[Musik]
und wenn sich das schon mal verbunden
hat gibt ihr auch direkt olivenöl mit
rein also etwa 6 ausgleichen
[Musik]
der teig dürfte bei mehr als acht
minuten durch kneten und jetzt fertig
kurz meine hände mit etwas olivenöl auch
hier diese arbeitsfläche dann nehme ich
nun silikon matte und da gebe ich jetzt
den teig drauf der klebt jetzt auch
nicht mehr weil er eben lange knetet
wurde und jetzt vorm ich ihn einfach nur
noch so zu so einer kugel
das ist jetzt auch ein teig da ist es
nicht zu weich aber eben trotzdem schön
geschmeidig jetzt hier eine kugel formen
und dann gebe ich jetzt hier etwas
olivenöl wieder in den topf zurück legt
die kugel wieder rein und verdeckte auch
schön mit olivenöl von trocknete nämlich
nicht aus und jetzt lasse ich den teig
abgedeckt circa eine halbe stunde bis
stunde gehen bis er sich verdoppelt hat
und entweder können sie das hier in der
kenwood machen oder einfach an einem
warmen ort also 30 grad reichen auf
jeden fall
und wenn er sich verdoppelt hat sehen
wir uns gleich wieder der hefeteig ist
jetzt schon aufgegangen und ich zeige
euch jetzt einfach mal kurz die zutaten
für die füllung lahmacun wird immer mit
hackfleisch gemacht als gibt es da
eigentlich auch keine vegetarische
alternative aus oder macht hat was ganz
anderes
und deswegen zeigen die zutaten ich
brauche 700 gramm hackfleisch ihre
rinder hackfleisch drei zwiebeln so
einen halben bund petersilie die sind
jetzt mal meiner terrasse etwas salz und
chili drei kleine paprika etwas
tomatenmark noch etwas besser und ich
habe hier bereits fünf tomaten und da
ließ sich jetzt direkt heißes wasser
drüber denn ich muss die tomaten heuer
erstmal häuten also die schale entfernt
[Musik]
man kann die natürlich auch pocher so
kreuzförmig einritzen
das klappt dann auch ganz gut auch wenn
man die jetzt so kurz 23 minuten stehen
lassen dann ist das wunderbar ich nehme
jetzt zuerst mal die petersilie die wird
schön fein gehackt und das mache ich
jetzt damit schneller geht und einfacher
geht einfach hier in der küchenmaschine
ich habe zwar dass mixa mit drin und
mixed es jetzt einmal durch jetzt nehme
ich das messer raus denn den rest möchte
ich nicht missen sondern fein reiben
oder was jetzt fein grob reiben deswegen
habe ich ihr die grobe reibe selbst ist
jetzt hier ein und ihr könnt es
natürlich auch ganz normal also dass die
petersilie messer schneiden ohne
zwiebeln mit der eine reibe ganz fein
reiben
[Musik]
jetzt nämlich noch die paprika dann
nehme ich hier oben jetzt diesen stil
weg und ich ihnen auch das kerngehäuse
[Musik]
und die reibe ich jetzt auch einmal
glücklich
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich die tomate und schäl sie
dann ist selbst aufpassen die sind noch
ziemlich heiß können sie auch war kurz
mit kaltem wasser abschrecken und jetzt
kann man hier mit dem messer ganz
einfach die haut abziehen
ich könnte natürlich auch dran lassen
aber die ist halt so ein bisschen härter
und dann hat man das später im mund und
das finde ich nicht so gut deswegen
nehme ich die schale lieber weg
[Musik]
und die tomaten werden jetzt auch einmal
durch gemixt
[Musik]
und jetzt gebe ich alle zutaten zusammen
in der große schüssel und zwar mache ich
das einfach hier ruhig wollen die
tomaten drin gehäutet habe alles rein
wir sind jetzt echt ganz tolle aromen
die sich jetzt hier verbinden
da möchte kann natürlich auch drei
scharfe paprika
aber ich mache das zeug nicht weil da
ist ja auch noch andere mit und dann
bekommt auch direkt das hackfleisch mit
dazu ca 2 teelöffel salz
ich nehme etwas chili da nicht zu viel
so ein halber teelöffel etwas pfeffer
dann gebe ich hier noch zwei esslöffel
tomatenmark mit dazu und wer möchte kann
das ganze noch mit getrockneter minze
und etwas oregano abschminken
das mache ich jetzt von beiden jeweils
einen teelöffel und es muss jetzt schön
durchmischt werden und weil ich das
jetzt nicht mit den händen machen will
um den löffel dauert es immer so lange
mache ich das jetzt kurz mit einem
handschuh einmal schenkt euch mixen
[Musik]
und jetzt ist die füllung bereit und ich
werde hier ganz schnell aufräumen und
dann zeige ich euch will man die lach
martin herstellt ich bat sie nehmen
jetzt den teig und zwar nehme ich mir
jetzt immer teig welchen mit 80 gramm
raus dann ergibt es so am ende ca 20
lahmacun und ich will mir immer ganz
gerne ab
[Musik]
und dann rolle ich sie zu einer schönen
kugel
das mache ich jetzt erstmal so mit 4 bis
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich den ersten tag war schon
mal ausrollen
ich mache sie ein herz genau zu mir
kriegt ein herz lahmacun aber jetzt erst
mal im kreis ganz normal
das geht am besten mit bislang mail
[Musik]
dann klopfe ich da so ein bisschen das
melap und setzt es hier auch seine
torten retter der angriff also das ist
ganz praktisch
es geht natürlich auch ohne und jetzt
kommt da bereits die füllung drauf und
zwar nehme ich da jetzt so etwa zwei
esslöffel so dass schon eine kleine von
kleiner shop schöpflöffel soundsoviel
löffel und kann bis dann verteilen
[Musik]
und ich packte sitz in einer pfanne aus
ihr könnt es natürlich auch im backofen
machen
im backofen werden die lahmacun er
knusprig und wenn ihr das in der pfanne
macht werden wir eben eher weit wobei
sie da am anfang auch als knusprig sind
und sie müssen ja immer nur von unten
gebacken werden
da gibt es sogar also meiner mama hat
sie extra wonach martin gerät sieht dann
aus wie so ein sandwich toaster jetzt
habe ich die person zu viel mehl
abgeklopft aber ich später einmal mit
dieser teig gut und schiebt das größter
traum
[Musik]
und jetzt schalte ich das hier auch
mittlere stufe hebt auch direkt den
deckel mit drauf und dann gab es jetzt
von unten und von oben also durch den
dampf dann eben auch von oben und unten
mit einem schön kross und während der
sitzung buck das sind so etwas zwei drei
minuten kann ich schon mal die
restlichen vorbereiten
[Musik]
man könnte einfach mal unten schauen
wenn es unten auch durch gebacken ist
dann eben das heraus ich lege das
meistens in so einem gefäß rhein mit
deckel
denn dann werden sie schön weich wenn es
jetzt knusprig lieber haben wollt müsst
ihr sie offen lagern und ohne deckel
aber ich möchte ja später auf rollen mit
salat deswegen dass ich sie weich werden
und nach dem ersten lahmacun schmecke
ich auch meistens schon mal ab ob salz
pfeffer und chili und so weiter stimmt
und wenn es nicht stimmt kann man sie
jetzt in erfüllung mit reingehen und ich
packe sie einfach mal die restlichen 19
aus
[Musik]
ihr könnt ihr auch einfach im backofen
backen da bei ober und unterhitze 240
grad etwa habe ich schon eingestellt so
auf mittlere bis obere einschub lässt
sich um 3 einschob leistet ich mache mal
so rein und da brauchen sie so etwa fünf
bis sieben minuten
ich habe jetzt schon fast alle lahmacun
ausgebacken und immer bevor ich ganz
fertig bin mache ich schon mal meinen
salat denn wer wikinger später an salat
dazu ein
und das sage ich jetzt einfach mal wie
ich den vita eben auch das dressing
mache und sich den zubereitet
als ich habe ja bereits schon mal eine
karotte geschehen das klingt die
rechtliche grenze
dann eine gurke die habe ich auch schon
geschehen und die schneidigen feinen
scheiben
kann ich schon mal die zwei zutaten hier
in die schüssel rhein geben
[Musik]
und jetzt schneide ich noch den
eisbergsalat und die zwei tomaten
einfach schön klein
[Musik]
dann kommt jetzt olivenöl dran so etwa
zwei esslöffel dann der saft von zwei
zitronen
[Musik]
und jetzt nur noch mit salz und pfeffer
würzen
[Musik]
jetzt zeige ich euch doch wir mal
lahmacun serviert als entweder ist man
sie so pur oder mit etwas zitronensaft
raus oder meine lieblings variante ist
mit salat
[Musik]
dann wird das schön eingerollt
und dann ist man das einfach aus der
hand heraus und dieses einrollen kann
jeder einfach am tisch machen also ich
stelle mal am arsch und salat salz und
pfeffer und zitrone hin und dann kann
das jeder ebenso belegen wer das möchte
bei mir kommt natürlich noch chili mit
rein aber das ist eine andere sache auf
jeden fall war es mein lahmacun rezept
ich hoffe dass es euch gefällt und die
erstmal nach macht und samira bekommt
auch gleich ihr herzen nach motto okay
kein salat wie immer und ihr dürft das
rezept gerne nachmachen es steht auch
dallas - blog.de und ich freue mich
wieder aufs nächste mal bis dann
[Musik]